there will be very many scenes on the
DVD I think ultimately I might argue one
or two little things I would have liked
to have put in the movie but generally
most of them belong on the DVD and and
people will see why and but but I am
still proud of them and and people will
see why we had them in the first place
but you know it's not one of those
things where it's like no wait the
director's cut
no this is the movie Paul Bettany onset
you know he comes in and although the
makeup is not complete because it's
gonna be some did you 2d effects on the
rendering of the face he is the vision
of that costume and he's quite tall and
bearing and then he's you know this is
gravitas that is overwhelming and and so
beautiful and then he speaks and he
there is nobody dorkier funnier more
irreverent or less vision like than paul
bettany and it's for some reason because
he's the vision when he's goofing around
it's just unbearably funny I cannot
repeat most of his jokes a vision is a
fascinating character for me because you
know he's he has this a a genuine
naivete at the same time as he has
clearly a wisdom and a balance that the
rest of us will never achieve and you
know and Paul is is wonderful at
conveying that sort of dichotomy at the
same time conveying genuine warmth with
real distance like you know he is
someone you would want to be with you
want him on your side you love him but
you also know that he's seeing something
you're not and he might be too polite to
tell you that it's something horrible
it's fun it's just fun there's just you
know being being back with all of them
you know they they really when we made
the first one they didn't know each
other cap hadn't come out for hadn't
come out
there's an ease now that they have and
they were they were great on the first
one but now it's you know there's the
unease also about what we're doing there
hadn't been an Avengers film and they
were very sweet and trusting about the
fact that they had no idea what it was I
was trying to do but now they do and so
we we come together really us as a
family except that we like each other
you